hi ich bin Marie und ich baue das Obst
und Gemüse für meine Familie fast
komplett selber an und wer regelmäßig
hier vorbeischaut könnte meinen ich gehe
morgens um 6 Uhr als erstes in den
Garten vielleicht nach einem kurzen
Abstecher zum See wo ich erstmal ein
paar Bahnen schwimme und dann kuschel
ich mit meinen Hühnern und verbringen
den Rest des Tages zwischen Kürbis und
Tomatenpflanzen ja ich liebe es richtig
doll draußen zu sein und mein Garten
oder allgemein selbstversorgung ist eine
riesengroße Leidenschaft von mir aber
manchmal habe ich Sorge dass meine
Videos ein unrealistisches Bild zeichnen
denn auf meinem Kanal geht es um das
Gärtnern und deswegen zeige ich euch ja
nur diese eine Seite aus meinem Leben
und das bedeutet dass alles was ihr zu
sehen bekommt Marie in Ihrem Garten ist
obwohl ich die wahrscheinlich die
meisten von euch meistens nur ein paar
Stunden am Wochenende damit verbringe
Gemüse anzubauen und der Rest ähm meines
Alltags ziemlich anders aussieht und
deswegen zeige ich euch heute einfach
mal mit und gebe euch einen echten
ehrlichen realistischen Eindruck und was
ich so den ganzen Tag mache wenn man
durch Social Media scrollt dann könnte
man meinen dass alle außer einem selbst
irgendwie so einen perfektes
harmonisches Leben führen es ist bei den
anderen irgendwie immer ganz ordentlich
und aufgeräumt und alle sind immer gut
gelaunt und alles scheint immer so toll
zu sein und ich habe nicht so Lust damit
zu machen ganz ehrlich ich zeige euch
jetzt einfach mal ganz unzensiert wie es
bei mir zu Hause gerade aussieht also
ich bin Mama ich habe eine Firma mit 12
Mitarbeitern und Mitarbeiterin und bin
durch meine Arbeit ganz viel unterwegs
und für auch noch eine Fernbeziehung und
es ist ganz ehrlich nicht immer leicht
das alles unter einen Hut zu kriegen ich
war hier gerade im Film und deswegen
liegt hier alles voll und vor allem ist
auf dem Boden überall irgendwie Stoff
weil das sonst zu doll halt hier im Raum
und alles was irgendwie im Weg liegt und
Stör beliebig wenn ich Filme einfach in
irgendeiner Ecke und ich weiß dass das
ganz ganz ganz viele Youtuber ganz
genauso machen von außen sieht man auch
oft gar nicht dass ich Wurzelwerk gar
nicht alleine mache Wurzelwerk ist ja
gar nicht nur dieser YouTube Kanal wir
haben auch einen Blog auf dem wir ganz
viele Anleitungen rund um das Thema
Selbstversorgung teilen also falls ihr
die noch nicht kennt schaut auf jeden
Fall mal vorbei und hier seht ihr unser
wunderschönes Büro wir haben auch ein
paar Büro Hunde das ist immer sehr sehr
schön und hier hängen Bilder von unseren
Kurs Teilnehmern und Kurs
Teilnehmerinnen weil der aller aller
aller größte Teil von Wurzelwerk besteht
darin dass wir ganz viele Leute durch
die Gartensaison begleiten das heißt wir
haben ein Videokurs der heißt
Gemüsegarten starten da erkläre ich ihn
über 50 Videos ganz genau wie man sein
Gemüse anbaut und wie man das auch so
anbaut dass man in dem hektischen Alltag
immer noch richtig viel erntet und
möglichst wenig Arbeit mit dem Garten
hat und das ist eigentlich so unser
tägliches Geschäft dass wir an den
Kursen arbeiten und die Leute durch das
Gartenjahr begleiten falls ich jetzt
jemand denkt oha das hat sich aber
richtig gut an wir öffnen am 4 Februar
diesen Jahres wieder unsere kurstüren
wir haben den Kurs meistens nur ein
relativ kurze Zeit im Jahr geöffnet wo
ihr euch anmelden könnt und er war bis
jetzt wieder ausverkauft also wenn ihr
dabei sein wollt dann meldet euch Anfang
Februar dafür an in der ersten Woche
gibt's auf jeden Fall auch noch eine
Rabattaktion und ich packe euch den Link
unten in die Video Beschreibung und wir
haben gerade eigentlich drei große
Projekte an denen wir im Wurzelwerk Team
arbeiten einmal ist es natürlich der
Gemüsegarten starten Kurs der steckt
eine der letzten Überarbeitung damit wir
dann Anfang Februar auch fertig sind mit
allem und der richtig toll für euch ist
dann möchten wir gerne auch Inhalte
erstellen für Leute die keinen Garten
haben und auf dem Balkon oder an der
Fensterbank Gärtnern und wir haben am
Büro zum Glück ein sehr sehr tollen
großen Balkon den wir jetzt dieses Jahr
richtig be gelassen werden ich gärtnere
bei mir zu Hause auch am Balkon aber ich
kann da nicht wirklich Filmen weil man
dann sieht wo ich wohne deswegen bin ich
sehr sehr dankbar um diesen Büro Balkon
und ich glaube das wird richtig toll wir
wollen den in so einen richtigen
Dschungel Balkon verwandeln also wenn
ihr irgendwelche
Wünsche habt was wir dafür Videos machen
sollen oder irgendwelche Probleme die
ihr beim Balkon Gärtner habt dann
schreibt uns das super gerne und dann
arbeiten wir seit ja schon der ganzen
Weile auch daran einen Onlineshop zu
erstellen und das erste große Projekt
ist für uns das Saatgut Abo da könnt ihr
euch anmelden und ähm bekommt dann
dreimal im Jahr immer rechtzeitig zur
Auszeit von uns ein Päckchen wir haben
auch gerade eine wunderbare
Illustratorin gefunden die botanische
Zeichnungen von unserem Sorten macht
damit wir richtig schöne Tütchen
gestalten können
das ist unsere Worte
botanisch korrekt
letztens waren wir zum Beispiel auch
unterwegs und haben uns die Verpackung
angeschaut in die mit ihr seid gut
abgefüllt werden soll und es gibt
Kartons die aus Gras hergestellt werden
und das ist super super schön einfach
nach nachhaltigen Möglichkeiten zu
suchen das macht gerade einfach so
wahnsinnig Spaß aus dem Nichts sowas
komplett Neues zu erschaffen und es ist
auch ein super gutes Gefühl alles in der
Hand zu haben weil mir Nachhaltigkeit
halt super wichtig ist und wir z.B jetzt
auch bei den ganzen
verpackungsentscheidungen und so richtig
tolle Sachen aussuchen können wir haben
ganz tolle Produzenten z.B aus dem
Erzgebirge gefunden für die kirschstäbe
und es wird richtige
wurzelwerkzeuge geben und vor allem
jetzt erstmal diese Saatgut Box also da
könnt ihr euch schon mal sehr sehr doll
drauf freuen wir haben fürs erste Jahr
leider nur eine begrenzte Anzahl an
Leuten für die wir diese Saatgut Box
erstellen können weil wenn nicht so viel
Saatgut haben deswegen wird es da eine
Warteliste geben falls wir schon soweit
sind das ist die schon gibt packe ich
die auch in die Video Beschreibung oder
genau ich finde auch alle Links in dem
obersten angepinnten Kommentar heute ist
dann auch endlich endlich unsere
Wurzelwerk App fertig geworden die ist
für all diejenigen von euch die in
unseren Kursen mit dabei sind und ihr
könnt ab jetzt die Kurse dann auch
offline im Garten schauen das war uns
immer ein großes Anliegen und wir haben
sehr sehr lange daran gearbeitet dass
möglich zu machen also hier kann man
dann
die einzelnen Module auswählen und
bisher konnte man unsere Kurse immer nur
im Laptop anschauen oder halt über den
Browser am Handy und jetzt geht das auch
direkt in der App ohne dass meine
Internetverbindung im Garten z.B hat
immer dabei die App ist auch einfach
wunderschön geworden also danke noch mal
vor allem an Katrin aus meinem Team die
da ganz ganz lange dran getüftelt hat
[Gelächter]
ihr redet übrigens auch immer jede Woche
in unserer Teambesprechung mit weil wir
nämlich immer eine liebe Nachricht
Vorlesen die wir von euch bekommen haben
und das ist immer ein Moment wo ich ja
mich sehr sehr doll freue und sehr
dankbar bin dafür dass ich diese Arbeit
machen darf und dass ich so viele Leute
dazu inspirieren darf rauszugehen und
loszuwerten also das ist wirklich der
Hammer
also ihr habt mich definitiv motiviert
dazu meinen eigenen Garten anzulegen ich
habe jetzt
900 miteinander gepachtet und genieße
jede Stunde die ich auf dem Land
verbringen darf vielen Dank für
eure Bilder einstellen
Sebastian gerade noch an einer Webseite
für unseren Onlineshop der bald
gelauncht wird es dauert nur noch so ja
zwei Monate ungefähr bis damit losgeht
und wenn ich diese Webseite sehe dann
habe ich so ein Kribbeln im Bauch weil
ich schon so so lange davon träume
diesen Shop endlich zu erstellen und für
mich ist das gerade noch komplett zu
Real und ich fühle mich wie so ein
kleines Kind ich weiß auch nicht weil
ich so hibbelig bin jedes Mal wenn es um
den Shop geht da auch wieder die Frage
an euch was sollen wir für Produkte
aufnehmen was wünscht ihr euch ich meine
jetzt gerade hat doch die Möglichkeit
euch komplett einzubringen weil ähm der
schaut gerade so mitten im Entstehen ist
also lasst uns gerne Kommentare da auch
so Video wünschen wir haben immer einen
offenes Ohr und wir wollen das alles
machen damit es euch richtig gut gefällt
deswegen brauchen wir euren Input aber
kommen wir noch mal zurück zum Garten
bei mir läuft auch nicht immer alles
perfekt gerade im letzten Jahr
wir sind einige Sachen ziemlich schief
gelaufen vor allem hatte ich eine große
Rattenplage und ich habe jetzt immer
noch nicht eine Sache die ich im Moment
ernten kann weil die Ratten alles
abgefressen haben also das war wirklich
sehr sehr extrem und sehr traurig aber
ich merke auch hier hektischer mein
Leben ist desto mehr brauche ich den
Garten um runterzukommen und genießt
dann die Wochenenden umso mehr wenn ich
mal mehr Zeit habe um draußen zu sein
und es gibt auch noch so eine Sache die
vielleicht auch viele von euch kennen
ich bin in der Fernbeziehung und dadurch
dass ich meinen Freund auch nur am
Wochenende sehen kann
steht ja schon in Konkurrenz zu meinem
Garten was nicht so toll ist weil ich
beide einfach ziemlich doll liebe und
klar kann man auch mal zusammen Zeit im
Garten verbringen aber manchmal möchte
ich ihnen dann auch einfach besuchen und
dann kommt es auch mal vor dass ich mal
drei Wochen überhaupt nichts im Garten
mache und
auch dann teilweise ein bisschen
überfordert bin wenn sich Sachen so
aufstauen also das geht mir ganz genauso
wie wahrscheinlich allen da draußen was
mir immer super doll hilft wenn ich so
ein bisschen nehmen Sie motivations tief
bin ist eine neue Projekte für meinen
Garten zu überlegen und so schauen wie
ich den vielleicht ein bisschen
aufhübschen kann so ein bisschen Ordnung
wieder reinbringen kann in mein inneres
Chaos auch und dazu findet ihr hier ein
Video wo ich euch verschiedene
Gartenprojekte vorstelle die einen
wieder so richtig in die Augen bringen
und ansonsten geht raus und macht die
Welt ein bisschen grüner aber bitte ohne
Stress und drückt das alles immer
perfekt sein muss